[Music]
okay
now a lot of people have been requesting
a karo khan with black
i listen to the requests so we are going
to play a karaoke
now the karakan i will introduce
historically after the game
um but the idea is not hard to
understand you are prepared it's one of
those openings like
the french it's a cousin to the french
completely different opening in spirit
but
the fundamental logic behind it is the
same you are preparing
the move d5 playing d5 immediately is
this candy
and already this is not a very dangerous
line for black he's going knight f3 and
he's
giving up control of the center now we
have a pawn in the center he doesn't
in addition this knight can be pinned
with bishop g4 which is kind of nasty in
the karakan
so white should play d4 here at least
get a normal exchange
carl which is not the most dangerous way
to play the car con
i'll introduce some of white's
possibilities after the game
drive a beige volvo and listen to
vivaldi
are you is that the person you think i
am
because you are sorely mistaken okay
this should be fine how should we cover
this
um not lexus either
never who do you think i am okay
bishop d7 or knight c6 actually both is
fine
but i like bishop d7 bishop d7 develops
a piece and simultaneously
uh essentially gets him to take the
bishop which allows us to
develop the night for free
okay um now what i want you to
understand is that
in many openings like the same
principles apply
as usual so for example here
um uh here
there's no special way in which we
develop our pieces we develop our pieces
normally
knight f6 e6 bishop d6 uh just because
it's a karaoke doesn't mean
you have to invent a whole new way of
developing and some people
tend to think that openings are like you
know different cultures
audi would be very nice but maybe in the
future uh
where you have different languages and
civilizations
but uh openings are are more like you
know they have similarities they have
differences
uh maybe cultures are a good comparison
you know different languages but
languages have cognates
they have similarities they have the
same concepts and you can think of
openings in that way i think
um so bishop can come to several places
i like bishop d6 because it centralizes
it bishop b4
is i know what a lot of people want to
play
but if he castles out of the pin i'm not
sure that i want to take the knight i'm
not sure it's worth
giving up the bishop uh in order to
slightly damage his spawn structure i
don't particularly like that approach
you're close kentucky friend measure
bishop d6 is what we're gonna do and
then we're gonna castle
okay
and i will reward myself well knight b5
is that's a good question actually
knight b5 bishop back to b8 is a good
response and then we can play a6 and
then chase the knight back at the end of
the day
we're gonna have um nobody's going to
gain
from this transaction
okay
yep you got it mr cali okay so
with that being said let's continue
bringing our pieces into the game yeah
roxy eight exactly
yeah groovy i i was originally going to
say that cultures is a bad analogy but
then i realize it's a good analogy
if you think of it the right way
okay 92 that's a good move right
he potentially is getting the knight
somewhere safe
but what does this allow us to play we
always when we get into this early
middle game we start thinking okay what
is the drawback of this move what
squares does it release
yeah 94 and then we can do the pillsbury
night if you guys remember from an
earlier speed run a pillsbury knight
is a knight on e4 or e5 supported by
neighboring pawns on
f and d which is what we're going to do
we don't need to play f5 and the knight
is defended perfectly well by the d-pawn
but the additional benefit of f5 not
only can the pawn go to f4
but also we can lift the rook up to h6
that's actually the tactical
benefit of playing f5
okay
yeah um it's named after harry nelson
pillsbury
it was an american chess player from the
uh early 1900s late 1800s
yeah um a lot of people might think well
doesn't this weaken the king and again
i've always emphasized
the relativity of this kind of argument
right the king can be weakened
you can run around in your apartment if
you live alone without any clothes on
without going you know without being
punished
when you visit your parents or your
family
you can't really do that right it's all
relative it depends on who's in the room
so who's in the room here well we've got
a lot of our own pieces in the room
white doesn't have all that much beef
going on on the king's side so we can
afford this
yeah you guys know that was a good
analogy see it's going to be memorable
what should we do he does attack the e61
mechanics chess my hometown chess club
rating with a party of 21.
thank you so much how do we do
several things at once we defend the
pawn but we also want to advance our
attacking agenda
how should we do that i don't know your
family well
i don't think i want to know yeah so
either a rook lift or a queen lift
i actually like the queen lift because
that actually
how should i explain this um
i guess not only does it defend the pawn
but the queen just seems to be a bit of
a safer defender than the rook
also there's some part of me that's
saying after rook f6 it puts the rook
and the queen on the same
file i'm sorry on the same diagonal and
maybe there's some bishop g5 pin
in the future uh the same idea we want
to get the queen potentially to h6 so
that it x-rays the h2 pawn
okay
yes the rook is the better defender
that's a good point but we are going to
dispense
with this knight with what move how are
we going to get rid of the knight
and don't tell me bishop takes f4 this
bishop is worth its weight in gold
if we take bishop takes f4 then we
weaken the e5 square
yeah g5 is right g5 chases the knight
away
opens up the bishop and um
then we can remove our queen at h6 and
the g5 pawn covers
it provides like an umbrella for the
queen how much does a bishop point
that's right
okay i hope everything is making sense
and i hope you guys are enjoying
i'm very happy to be back home and we're
going to keep grinding
lots more to come thank you everybody
for the support
we are holding strong in your 7 000 subs
which is amazing
and uh i really really appreciate it so
we'll play this one one game we'll
analyze
and i'll call it a night
but lots of streams coming up thank you
kaiser 3 for the tier 1.
yeah i don't know what lilo recommends
sorry for the glitch with the lack of
blitz
hopefully by the evening it will be
restored night spoon gifting
first gifted sub to rave day thank you
so much rave the day
appreciate it okay so g5 is coming up
basically against anything he does
that's from the chest and it's actually
not a stockholm but it is a wooden set
it's a cool set okay so g5 here we go
get out of here
get out of f4 opening up the bishop and
another sub bluish bubble
gifting to the jug really appreciate it
okay
excuse me i also have to eat and stuff
and
well i already did but more
okay 96 that is panic that is just panic
that is why we put the queen on f6 this
gives up a knight not sure what he sees
here i think knight g5 may have misled
him
that actually ends up blundering another
knight because the queens are in a
standoff
notice how i immediately point this out
right
because the moment i noticed that that
gives you the power to control it and he
just
kind of missed the mark here this often
happens you panic and and sort of things
collapse but
at this point black white's position was
already quite unpleasant
although knight d3 would give a much
much better game than taking on e6 i
mean g4
maybe an f4 is coming in this is very
unpleasant for
white but the game would have went on
had this happened okay
good game dmd i appreciate it now
the karo khan is caro dash con
so it's not one word and surprisingly it
is named after two people
you guys will never guess what their
names are their names are karo and khan
i mean amazing chess players are very
original
horatio caro and ilya khan were two
masters i don't they were not
grandmasters they were masters
and they lived in approximately the same
time um um sorry marcos khan
1820 to 1886 and horatio caro english
player austrian player was caro
1862-1920 so
19th century second half of the 19th
century was when they played they both
played the karo khan
as with so many other openings neither
karo nor khan
was actually the first person to play
the karo khan
by a very wide margin the first person
to play the karakan 1845
a guy named withers john withers in a
casual game in bristol england
played c6 and d5 against elijah williams
thank you dmd
my opponent gifting five mile lands then
uh indian players soma karana played in
1856
uh shimon winauer one of the strongest
polish players
played in 1883 and only in 1884
marcus khan plays the karo khan and
loses his first game with it
but he stuck with it and won a couple
others
now i'm looking this up in chess base i
don't have this in my head
although that would be nice anyways
um that is a little story of the karo
khan
and why was it not played in the 1700s
because
that was back in the day when you know
not controlling the center was
considered unacceptable so that's why
people played e5
exclusively right because this controls
mo more of the center
then people started to realize right
that it wasn't necessarily
about the amount of the center you
control but about the quality of the
central control
so d5 establishes a very nice stronghold
uh the conline of the sicilian is named
after ilya khan i think
russian player eliakhan so
basically what is the drawback of the
car economy i'm talking about it like
it's the best opening it's actually one
of the best openings i believe
unlike the french right in the french
what is the main drawback of the french
why don't more people play it from a
positional standpoint this is a very
famous property of the french that
disawaits a lot of people from playing
it it's the bishop right chesket
is the ultimate authority on that
so the bishop is bad the french bishop
in the cairo gun we circumvent this
problem
so why doesn't everybody play the card
well first of all we take away the c6
square from r9
the knight often has a very hard time
getting active it often has to go to d7
which is a more passive square
the second thing is that if white plays
the advanced car which is d4
and then e5 um
in the car account we play bishop f5
right that's the improvement over the
french
but we've essentially spent a lot of
time preparing this move
and what's going to happen is that in
order to assail white's pawn chain
we're going to spend have to spend
another move playing c5
kind of playing it like a french but
down several tempe so we do get the
bishop out but we pay
a bunch of tempe for and this could give
white a very big initiative
in the opening if black is not very
careful white also has a big space
advantage and much like in the french
this d6 square is a very big weakness
thank you ben i am and thank you badou
for the raid with the party of 121.
thank you so much badour i'm on the tail
end of my stream
but i'm doing great thank you so much
for the raid welcome people
a big honor always to be raided by gm
badur jibawa
one of my heroes of course i played the
job as one of my full-time openings
so thank you thank you thank you very
much and welcome people to the tail end
of a speed run
uh today's stream is a little bit short
i just got off a plane
so five hour flights are not fun
but nonetheless very happy to be
streaming welcome everybody
okay so uh hopefully that makes
some sense now the way that white plays
it i recommend the two knights that's a
good way to play against the carl
without playing d4
develop development first that's gotten
very popular recently math school thank
you
and do wow i can't even keep up with
this do belly zigzag gifting to bad or
um now this is a not a terrible way to
play it but it's not very ambitious
because now we get
upon on d5 we get more of the center and
we get
quick development for our pieces so this
is about equal now the move knight c3 is
a positional inaccuracy could somebody
explain to me why
why is this move uh inaccurate it's not
a big mistake it's not like a huge
blunder but it is inaccurate
yeah so you want to be able to move the
c pawn either to c3
in order to build up a pawn chain or to
go c4 and assail the d5 pawn
either way i i recommend c3 here
and then what move should white play
which of these two pieces
should he develop first the bishop of
the knight and if so where
yeah in the jabbawa london you do play
knight c3 but
there are extenuating circumstances that
permit that
yeah definitely the bishop to f4 to stop
bishop d6
if you move the knight first you're
going to have a hard time developing the
bishop and you let black have this very
nice square
so this is equal white's not worse there
black is very comfortable
but that would create an equal position
the way that you develop dmd it's not
terrible but it's a little bit passive
and already at this point that knight
could get in
in a meat grinder if i play bishop
before at the right moment
and moving the knight is not bad but now
i get the pillsbury night
so i think your second mistake which got
you kind of on the brink
is is probably here although maybe the
computer will find a way to get a good
position for white even after knight f4
but i think knight f4 allows me to
deploy my queen and then this move g5
comes with great effect it's a move with
tempo i want to play this move anyway
now it happens with tempo
could somebody propose an alternative
this is not an easy position to handle
with white
but you guys should think of this in
terms of eliminating
black's strongest attacking pieces we
know that this bishop
is a very annoying attacking piece that
is the engine behind this entire attack
because it
pressures the f2 button so i like the
move bishop f4 now obviously black could
do the same thing
but with the bishops traded that is a
very important difference
how does that difference manifest itself
let's say the same thing happens as in
the game
and after knight t3 who can explain to
me why the trade of dark-squared bishops
is so beneficial
for white what additional thing does
white
have here and not a hard question i'm
setting you guys up here of course but i
just want everybody to understand the e5
square is better controlled
so if we are to compare this position
directly to
um to this position 95 is not well it's
possible
but white's going to have to sack a pawn
and he doesn't get control of that
square
if you compare this to this position
with the absence of the bishops white
gets a counter outpost on e5 furthermore
he can now chase away black's knight
with f3 so i would not have done this
had you gone bishop f4 i would have to
play in a more restrained fashion
and the idea of knight d395 is white's
plan here in addition you can now play
c3
so does that make sense um i probably
would have played
what would i have played here it's
actually not that easy for black um
now the computer likes g5 anyway it's a
very computerish approach it wants to go
here and then it wants to basically
orient itself toward an attack against
white's king i'm not sure that that's
the best approach
i think a more human human idea would be
perhaps to just move the bishop away
from
uh from d6 and then redeploy it to f6
you know and then from f6 it's going to
be very hard to
get rid of right white's not going to be
able to play bishop g5 that is
controlled
so that is one possibility
uh so that's essentially the arc of the
game um the caracon is a very peaceful
opening you're not gonna win too many
quick games with it
but it is an opening that allows you to
develop your positional knowledge
to develop your knowledge of how to
develop to develop your knowledge of
development development of pieces
and uh it is relatively theoretical at
the high levels so the high levels you
have to know
a ton of different opening a ton of
different variations the advanced
this is like the open main line there's
even the fantasy which is f3
where you try to control the center and
have all of it
also a very dangerous line by the way
but at a
15 1600 level i highly recommend it to
players who are looking to get better at
positional chess
you might lose a bunch of games at first
there is a steep learning curve but you
will get better at these positional
concepts if you
allow yourself to play these openings
the narrow con is queen f3
so that is i think formally called the
goldman variation that's where you go
queen f3
and you apply immediate pressure on this
pawn you try to get the spawn to move
so you can get the bishop out to c4 and
attack f7
not amazing black has many ways to
equalize
but interesting and this has a lot of
traps
um one of which is of course this lineup
showed many times
where black kind of plays it like a
french
thinking ah this knight on c3 means
white cannot play c3 and defend the pawn
train
white's pawn train collapses but of
course this crazy night
sally two night sally's win the game
because of all these threats i've won
several games like this
okay so that essentially is the arc of
the game any questions before i end for
today
so the exchange caro is not nearly as
boring as the exchange french the
exchange caro is a very legitimate
opening
because it creates an imbalance right it
creates a central imbalance or black as
the e pawn white as the sea
pawn but this the exchange french
is yeah the narrow con the exchange
french is
incredibly boring because it's
symmetrical that doesn't mean you can't
play interesting games in the exchange
range that doesn't mean
nobody should play the exchange french
it just means
that's how you compare these all right
guys
[Music]
you